[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie Happy
New Year you may have seen the news
about Quicksilver coming back into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe there were a
couple scenes that posted online that
Marvel took down very very quickly
meaning that they're probably real so
I'll explain what was going on during
that but this is huge news so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing the new infinity saga box set
giveaway I'll also explain that at the
end of the video - so late last night a
whole bunch of clips for two twin boys
performing as Wiccan and speed scarlet
which envisions children for the
upcoming one division and Doctor Strange
- posted online I made sure to download
them before Marvel took them down of
course but because of the hard core
rules that YouTube has about putting
little kids in your videos I can't
actually put them in the video here so
I'll explain what they were talking
about what the scenes were and what it
all means last year a couple casting
breakdowns revealed that they were
planning on doing scarlet which
envisions comic-book children during the
wand division series so it's not a huge
surprise that the actual children are
showing up but it's what they're talking
about what they're doing in the scenes
that implies that Quicksilver is also
coming back as part of all this
craziness one of the little kids is
named Tommy and he's talking to another
little kid presumably his twin brother
called Billy
so Tommy is the name of speed in the
comics Billy is the name of Billy Kaplan
Wiccan in the comics I think they're
gonna be changing their backstories a
little bit for the purposes of Wanda
vision in Doctor Strange - and possibly
future Young Avengers stuff so I'll
explain that stuff in a second it's not
quite as important as what they're
actually doing during these scenes so
Tommy is talking to Billy and they're
really afraid to go disturb their
quote/unquote uncle who's sleeping on
scarlet which envisions living room
couch late into the morning they dare
each other to go wake him up but they
never refer to him as anything more than
their uncle in the important thing about
Scarlet Witch and vision is that vision
doesn't have any biological family I
mean obviously we're doing the twins
from the comics I'll explain how that
works in a second because technically he
can't have biological children there's a
really crazy comic book explainer for
that but Scarlet Witch does have a
brother who would be these little boys
uncle so that's why everyone is taking
this to mean that whatever
chaos magic alternate reality multiverse
way that they're using to explain how
Scarlet Witch is physically capable of
having biological children with vision
they're also using that same way to
explain how they can bring back
Quicksilver when we saw him die during
Avengers age of Ultron you also remember
that dr. strange too is called the
multiverse of madness in Agatha Harkness
is supposed to be one of the characters
on the Wanda vision series played by
Kathryn Hahn
she's a very powerful sorceress from the
comics who's had a very contentious
relationship with Scarlet Witch in the
past Kevin Feige said that they were
using Wanda vision to turn Wanda of the
MCU into the true Scarlet Witch version
of her character from the comics and he
flat out just said that she's the new
most powerful character after avengers
endgame in that video that I posted
yesterday so the most logical
explanations for this is she could
either be living out her fantasy life
that she creates for herself with vision
like the twins maybe Quicksilver in an
alternate reality or they could go the
full Chaos magic route
either way the implication is that when
she does create this fantasy reality for
herself as they've been hyping up for
the Wanda vision series
it has far-reaching consequences and
that's why Doctor Strange gets involved
in why she winds up crossing over into
Doctor Strange to imagine what he would
do if he found out that Scarlet Witch
created an alternate reality in that
alternate reality started to spill into
our main reality there's that funny clip
from Avengers infinity war where Doctor
Strange is having his big bro off moment
with Iron Man and tells him exactly what
his main job is sorcerer supreme is this
still maybe the best chance we have
against that is so converse they may
also be his best chance against us so if
we don't do our jobs what is your job
exactly besides making balloon animals
protecting your reality so when I say
that scarlet witch's fake reality might
be causing problems for the main reality
that will probably have something to do
with the main villain of Doctor Strange
too because it sounds like Wanda vision
is one part then doing the Tom King
vision run with some changes letting
Scarlet Witch spend a few hot minutes in
the perfect life she imagined for
herself envisioned in their potential
children that she always wanted for
herself but never got a chance to have
then the second part of the series is
her being upgraded to comic book Scarlet
Witch chaos magical level powerful is
that fake reality starts to crack and
crumble around her
during the tonking vision run they kind
of did a version of this with visions
character Scarlet Witch isn't a big part
of it because he creates a separate
synthezoid family for himself but it all
just goes completely to [ __ ] by the end
of it but if they are bringing back
Quicksilver during wand division as part
of this fake reality it might only be
for a few hot minutes I don't know if
they have any plans to let some of her
fake realities stick eventually going
forward into the future because there
are a lot of people that think that
Kevin Feige is also using this series to
introduce Wiccan and speed so that they
can go off into a young Avengers team-up
they are core original founding members
of the first young Avengers comic book
team the video clips we saw were for
little kids though but the casting
breakdowns that we got last year that
said that they were trying to do Scarlet
Witch envisions children talked about
kids that would age rapidly that would
be a really easy way to explain how they
can be born and then within the span of
a few years be old enough for a young
Avengers team-up but it's not clear how
much of this wand of vision stuff is
going to show up during Doctor Strange
too or if they'll just have some quick
montage and some references to the
events of Wanda vision and all that
craziness during the beginning of Doctor
Strange - for some context because you
have to imagine there's always that one
person that just completely ignores
everything that Marvel does and then
they see a big movie they go to see it
and they have no idea how Scarlet Witch
got so powerful at the beginning of it
after avengers endgame wait a minute
where did she learn to do chaos magic
where did that happen remember how they
just announced the wand a vision was
coming out later at the end of this year
instead of waiting until 2021 to release
it one of the big reasons I think
they're doing that is because they're
probably gonna release the first big
trailer for Doctor Strange - at the end
of this year in scarlet which is gonna
show up in it looking very different
being super powerful Marvel wants people
to understand why that is so that's why
you need the wand division series to
explain how all this crazy stuff starts
happening I know a lot of you outside
the United States are like wait a minute
I can't even watch the wand division
show because they don't have Disney Plus
in my country most of the countries
around the world will have Disney Plus
by the time all this Marvel stuff starts
airing in the fall first it's gonna be
Falcon and Winter Soldier which will
start sometime in August or September
that'll run all their episodes then
they'll do all the wand division
episodes then they'll do the mandalorian
season - but while all that's happening
they'll start dropping clips and
trailers
or dr. strange to a lot of you are also
asking if they're using the concept of
scarlet which envisions children on the
series to introduce the concept of
mutants formally into the MCU the x-men
characters and I think it's a little
more complicated than that because of
their crazy back story in the comics so
I think the way they're gonna play it is
gonna be a little more subtle in the
real x-men mainstream a less characters
like Wolverine the core x-men characters
you'll see pop up in a separate film one
division will probably just be the back
door to that stuff so you'll say there's
some Easter eggs and references in there
setting up that down the road laying
seeds you also remember the famous
conversation that Kevin Feige had at
comic-con where he said that each of the
new projects during phase four the
movies the TV shows will lay seeds for
the big stuff that's coming later on
that includes bringing the x-men
characters into the MCU that's part of
the reason why Kevin Feige now controls
all of Marvel television shows and the
movies and the comics so that it all
works together and you have seeds of
everything laid in each different
project so that all connects together
the space for start to plant the seeds
for whatever we're gonna see because we
obviously saw Thanos the whole Infinity
Saga the seeds were planted way early on
yes we debated what we should announce
today should we announce four and five
we've planned them out we've got five
years down the road and I was like I
think you got eleven projects in two
years is plenty it's still not super
clear who the main villain of Doctor
Strange 2 is going to be but it does
sound like it's going to be someone as
big if not bigger than Dormammu so right
now it kind of seems like Agatha
Harkness might wind up being the secret
backdoor villain of one division she's
not a big enough character to be the
main villain of Doctor Strange - so it
sounds like Scarlet Witch and Agatha
Harkness cause a whole bunch of problems
for our reality during Wanda vision and
then that creates an opportunity for the
main villain of Doctor Strange to to
come into our reality which is where
Doctor Strange gets involved protecting
our reality let me know in the comments
though do you think the Scarlet Witch
envisions children talking about their
uncle scarlet witch's brother implies
that they're bringing back Quicksilver
for Wanda vision and who do you think
the main villain of Doctor Strange 2 is
gonna wind up being do you think it's
going to be nightmare or do you think
that it's going to be Mephisto
because even though everything is
pointing to it not being Mephisto
Mephisto is a core part of the origin
story of Scarlet Witch envisions
children they originally start out as
the soul shards that Mephisto then
reabsorbs into himself but then because
they're so powerful they get
reincarnated into other bodies of wicken
in speed so that's how scarlet witch's
children in the comics are actually born
technically to other people around the
United States and she doesn't learn
about it till later if you haven't read
any of those comics and you think that
sounds really confusing don't worry the
version of all that stuff that they do
on the TV shows will be very very
different
like I said we're doing the new infinity
saga box set giveaway I have a second
one to giveaway I'll leave that open
until Black Widow comes out in the
spring
everyone click here for that new Doctor
Strange video where Kevin Feige talks
about how Scarlet Witch is the new most
powerful character and click here for my
brand new Marvel Deadpool 3 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
Happy New Year
[Music]